[Music]
at Oh 427 a squad car got a call stand
speeding near old downtown officers
reported shots fired they found bodies
everywhere I would take that make ass
the city is crawling with dirty cops
nice gentlemen Nevada's finest looking
for this
this is downs homicide Jennifer Bryan
more Internal Affairs be bad police one
I like that
drop him off at 9 p.m. yeah when are you
moving home son
I love you there's some things I can't
explain you just have to trust me
[Music]
Vincente downs you stole something from
me bring it back or your sons not coming
home they said it was just gonna be an
easy group what it ain't no easy grab
they got teeth what is going on the
other side find him
got a problem I got in a we've got a lot
of enemies got a lot of people try to
train me on my energy
whatever you aim in it make sure you
prepared to kill but working on a couple
for two years he knows the players he
knows their methods
I'll pay every cop our payroll you see
Vincent downs dead
[Music]
you touch myself I'll kill you I got
enemies got a lotta enemy